all right Maria yes Maria where you from
Versailles Mexico
yes good part of the United States
hiding for people yeah well they're all
connected so yeah well basically they're
just like well this is why I got Iran
because I got tired of doing what they
want me to do because I I just need it
out I was 17 mmm I'm 52 I know they were
asking me to like go rob the peoples
that
whatever's that's why I got short hair I
used to have long hair before so you're
right
yeah yeah they're looking for a female
yeah whether you see you like yeah okay
so yeah so then that I tell then that I
just got tired just I want to do me you
know yeah that's well last time we had
an interview we couldn't remember I
guess because I can't stay still I gotta
move
I gotta keep hiding yeah well yeah I
brought I went in the house and did some
damages had a slice of throats
yes sliced it later too I had to I had
to do it in there was Emma me
how many people evening you heard
total like 18 years
how many years like maybe we leave from
that shoe I've been here like 13 years
you know no kids looking yeah my mom's
over there in Texas no not really here
no I can't yes so not even my phone put
it like that
so I just
so you murder people it wasn't
necessarily something you chose to do no
I did chose to do that without yeah of
course is that something you know
actually it that sounds like I didn't
really didn't matter you can go ahead
and tell me to do anything and I'm yeah
now it's like how differently I ask you
to grow older just a job yeah yeah
that's it yes
well yeah yeah oh yeah I used to laugh
about it but yeah do you think committee
makes it easier I do I do I get an
appetite
I want a life I gave my anger line in
mix and it's like I try to control
myself because I already know cuz you
know you're right so I try to either to
walk away or just by my tongue and just
sometimes I just I just said I send an
ad to a hospital because I was so upset
where her eye almost popped her eyes out
just my fist what kind of precautions do
you take I cut my hair I just move
around different areas yeah course yeah
like right now I just came from Morris
County I'm um just everywhere you up
yeah I have to
I'm sorry would
so you I haven't I haven't since I
definitely I mean I like here is uh you
know like she's in the hospital but I
can't get they don't know nothing
yeah it's kind of like messed up yes
yeah I'm just innocent but I don't I'm
telling you that I don't I don't carry
nothing with me with my idea or no no
that stuff yeah I don't know as many as
they want yeah yeah it's just like game
I guess were you a troubled youth before
this happened yeah when I was younger
yeah yeah yeah anybody I mean I mean if
they tell you a I need to do this but
again yeah okay yeah it was real yeah
I'm gonna definitely do it
and if you didn't you know prison time
yes yeah yeah touch it for armed robbery
yeah yes all right
you welcome thank you thank you thank
you